today I'm joined by Ildefonso Leonov
who's the founder and CEO of well
network they're online at join well
dot-com in the middle of an ICO and
really working in an area that I've been
following for a while which is
telemedicine and you know Eldar
especially here in the US we have such
problems in general with the healthcare
system a lot of it has to do with how
healthcare is paid for there's really no
shortage of problems to discuss but I'm
curious to start with you sort of what's
the key problem that you're looking to
solve so we're solving we call ourselves
Airbnb of healthcare and just like
Airbnb solved the problem of trust where
you entrust a stranger with the keys to
your house healthcare you and Trust keys
to your health to your sometimes life
and death so the key problem we're
trying to solve is basically medical
errors misdiagnosis not non-treatment
and even deaths caused by you know
healthcare and we solve it with
blockchain to ensure trust to scale
trust which blockchain is great for and
then another problem we solve is the
issue of payment friction which I
actually encountered as healthcare
provider of three years and so
blockchain for us is a solution that
we're you know solving our own you know
our own problems as a healthcare
provider and problems of other doctors
other health care providers so from the
end-user perspective we can then after
talk about maybe from the service
provider perspective or even from the
insurance company to the extent you'll
work with insurance companies if
everything goes to plan what would the
experience be for the end user the
consumer of healthcare that would be
available to them so it would depend on
country that they're in obviously
because healthcare is geography specific
in you know globally it may involve more
things like medical tourism
so basically
when a person wants to self pay for
something at the moment and once you get
the best possible care at the best
possible price we provide that and
whether it's medical tourism or even you
know second opinion or care in the
United States yeah and if someone is in
the United States to start with right
now the sort of typical relationship is
usually through an employer you have
health insurance there's typically some
kind of restricted limited list of
providers that you are able to go to if
you want full coverage or as close to
full coverage sort of as possible there
is a mechanism through which you might
pay a copay or coinsurance and then the
provider will bill the insurance and
then there's sort of a transaction that
takes place in that way what's the
opportunity of introducing blockchain
into this whatwhat is that
allow to happen that would otherwise not
be possible so the main the main problem
it solves is the payment friction so
there is a lot of mistrust and in
healthcare where insurance company may
approve a visit for example and you
happily go and you get thirty visits
with the physical therapists at a clinic
and it was pre-approved
everything is great they approved it
everyone is happy and then when you're
done with thirty visits suddenly they
only approved twenty so now it's a game
of musical chairs between the physical
therapy clinic and the patient and you
can't really do anything you can't sue
insurance you can't fight it and so what
happens is that either a patient gets
screwed or in this case a clinic gets
screwed and so ultimately blockchain is
perfect for removing middlemen which
insurance companies are really that
they're nothing but tape are shufflers
right
there's definitely underwriting but
that's really at the kind of the top
level
you know of insurance catastrophic
insurance insurance for like really high
levels of care you know like things like
cancer and things like that which are
available and you can get at
significantly lower cost and there is
even gap insurance that is available you
know as an alternative to HMO and PPO
already so that would be kind of the
format that we would provide to people
so one of the groups I guess I would say
one of the communities in the United
States anyway that really has limited
access to health care services are all
sorts of different underprivileged
groups people who don't have a job or
who have a job but it's not one that
provides insurance or individuals who
are self-employed or sort of
precariously employed and may not be
able to afford private market insurance
for themselves how can the project
you're working on here help to increase
access for those individuals so I'll
give you an example of my girlfriend who
is in fashion industry and she you know
as you know there's a lot of change in
fashion industry
she works for zsa and so she has
insurance right now she pays a lot of
money for it she needed an MRI of her
knee and she went with her insurance
provider and they didn't really cover it
they provided a 10% discount so $2,400
MRI would have cost her twenty two
hundred dollars in our system of our
providers which we negotiate just like
an insurance company can she was able to
get an MRI for $400 where blockchain
comes in is that we can actually save
additional money and headache and and
insure these providers that they will
get paid for sure because even with
insurance companies they negotiate those
extreme rates right like let's say her
MRI was covered then most likely
insurance would have paid $400 to that
provider but that provider
may have had to spend a year trying to
collect from that insurance company or
in the end not even cover it and then
they would have to basically send that
patient to a collection agency because
as a patient you sign a waiver saying if
insurance doesn't cover you are
responsible for the payment and that's
where blockchain is perfect with smart
contracts and you know ability to
basically ensure that the payment
happens and it's great for everyone
except for the middleman I'm interested
in the telemedicine angle I mean this is
something that even I think my primary
care provider here in Boston even offers
for certain types of visits certain
types of sort of common complaints
I'm already able to sort of
videoconference with I think it's a
nurse practitioner or not a doctor
rather than going in and I think it's
usually a benefit to them because it
keeps the office sort of clearer it's a
benefit to me because I pay either no or
a lower copay although I'd have to look
into it I haven't done it yet
but bigger picture I mean telemedicine
has huge potential right now although
there are still some caveats to that can
you talk about the telemedicine angle
well I'll expand it to even higher
basically what you want to do is a
provider and as a patient is you want to
match the problem with the solution so
you solve a $20 problem with the $20
solution and $2,000 problem with the
$2000 solution unfortunately because
healthcare is so inefficient it what
ends up happening is that sometimes $20
problem is solved with $2000 solution
and vice versa and the $2000 problem is
sold with $20 sorry a lot of tubes but
so basically what telemedicine is is
just one of the solutions to like you
said make air more efficient as far as
the doctor it doesn't really provide a
whole lot of benefit for that particular
doctor because if he spends you know 10
minutes with you he would spend the same
10 minutes with you in the office really
it's a convenience for the patient and
so what you want
sure is that you have even a layer below
it we call it secure messaging we're
with AI and ability to basically answer
questions you can you know sometimes
solve let's say $2.00 problem with the
$2.00 solution and so telemedicine to me
is not just the video call you make with
the doctor telemedicine to me is you
know let's call it telemedicine
telehealth whatever you want to call it
it's basically virtualization of care
where you know you basically have
solutions that are virtual to apply to
to you know to you to care to stay ahead
of the disease in case of IOT so you
know we're talking to large Asian
publicly traded company about a
partnership where you could have you
know IOT devices to basically measure
you know things like metabolism your
heart rate variability and things like
that
and for people who don't know IOT is
Internet of Things and that's right one
of the new sort of directions that that
a lot of these devices are going so you
were you were mentioning the potential
for remote reading of blood pressure
what other sort of applications would
there be so you can measure metabolism
you can you know like with GMA you can
give your you know saliva test and you
know have DNA measure to for example
ensure that you do the proper diet or
you watch out for certain things like
you know let's say you are
african-american male that's older than
40 years you have a high risk of you
know certain cancers or you know
whatever whatever group you are with
like DNA testing for example you can
turn an even higher probabilities of
certain things based on your DNA and so
then you adjust your behavior arm
offline to make sure you use the head of
potential problems
is there a difference in the sort of use
case for what you're doing depending on
the country people are in as a result of
just the drastically different health
systems that people have now in other
words we've been studying of course the
American system for a long time we are
now learning more our audiences about
the Singapore healthcare system which is
very different to what they have in the
United Kingdom for example so are the
applications and use cases for what well
network is doing very different from
country to country so overall you want
to start kind of with the end in mind
and then you you build a solution right
so the the main problem we're solving is
we're basically empowering people so for
the people by the people with the help
of blockchains
so in countries like Singapore or Hong
Kong where or even Canada where care is
kind of like you be you being taken care
of by the government but there's there
are times when you want that second
opinion for a very large problem or you
don't want to wait for a year for a
procedure and you have the money and you
want to spend it efficiently and with
the best possible care so that's the
solution there and again with providing
the substrate of virtual care let's call
it you can basically determine what your
solution is and then and then obtain it
on our platform so in countries where
working through insurance is the status
quo like the United States is there a
plan to work with insurance companies
directly yes so and that's a long-term
plan initially the plan would be to work
with self-insured employers and provide
them gap care and now with Trump you
know coming down on Obamacare
there's definitely and there's actually
gap in in care when you don't sign up on
time you can't get HMO PPO for several
months sometimes so this high deductible
plan that we're talking about
we're you covered for catastrophic but
then you go and you get when you do need
it you get extremely good prices that
use or your employer pays for right and
it's great for companies with you know
Millennials or other kind of population
types that need that type of care and
benefit from it the most to decrease
their cost of health care from the
perspective of the health insurance
company what's their incentive to work
with you so we've had we've been you
know talking speaking at several
conferences and we have insurance
companies come to us the most
interesting aspect for insurance
companies is basically so you have
Kaiser in the way they solve it the way
they solve that problem $20 problem $20
solution mm is they own the whole value
chain but it's a very you know you can
only do so much right it's health care
is a gigantic industry so Kaiser is you
know a very geographically focused and
then they own the entire value chain
Oscar is trying to do the same thing and
they're spending a lot of money but what
they're actually getting is they get a
huge population of Hispanics speaking
which even though they have the
technology they're trying to do but
because of their population sample
they're basically getting people still
wanting to come to the office and you
know we are and really expensive kind of
per patient expense so and as part of
that just to make sure I understand the
example part of that is that they don't
feel that short of going in they're
necessarily going to get someone who
understands them possibly because of a
language issue that also educationally
they just don't know about their options
right so yeah I'm not I'm not trying to
be a racist I'm just you know it's just
it's just realities of life right like
when people don't know their options
like you said they they just they
instead of being
they they go or they end up any you know
going to you are because they don't know
better yeah I think probably it would
even apply I mean I think it would apply
to any underserved or immigrant
community I mean here in Massachusetts
and particularly familiar partially
because of my family working in mental
health that immigrants from
spanish-speaking countries definitely
fall into that other parts of the
country could be other populations yeah
absolutely and and so for insurance
company is what makes it interesting
working with us is that essentially they
can get Kaiser like you know ability to
control the value chain without actually
owning it so think of it as like you
know there's Apple that controls
everything right they build the hardware
they build the software and then there's
Android where they provide the platform
that people can use but they get a
similar experience and so that's kind of
you know from that perspective that's
what we would strive to do for insurance
companies is give them Kaiser alike
capability to match the cost with a
solution and control with smart
contracts and frictionless payment and
also it basically would by outsourcing
trust to you know a third-party
blockchain in this case they can
basically ensure that their providers
will know and will be comfortable
working with that particular insurance
because that's a huge problem for
insurance companies is that people don't
want to work with them because they you
know they they want to be paid and they
you know sometimes these small insurance
companies that's how they manage cost
yeah let's talk about the token and the
ico a little bit what will the token do
so the token is the utility token you
basically will be able to pay for
services some you know subscription
services you know as far as like you
know the IOT
things ability to manage your care
you'll be able to store your data on our
blockchain and then the really big
problem we're solving is cross-border
payments so for example let's say a
Korean Serge plastic surgeon and the
Chinese lady that's trying to get a
plastic surgery if it's over ten
thousand dollar surgery with the new
laws in China well you can't really even
bring more than ten thousand dollars in
cash
and then making a cashless is a is a
very clunky transaction out of China for
example where you can't you know you
can't really take money out but but with
well tokens you can frictionlessly you
know convert your your fee ad into well
tokens and then a doctor converts it
back some of it backs he keeps some of
it
it also has potential tax saving
implications for the Korean plastic
surgeon as well what's the status of the
ICO right now we're in presale and where
people learn more about them join well
dot IO or join welcome which redirects
to join wall that il either one and
what's the timeline are there multiple
phases in terms of the deployment how
much are you looking to raise so we're
raising twenty eight million dollars
hard cap is our our hard cap is twenty
eight million dollars and we exceeded
our soft cap of three million we're in
public presale right now and IC o----
starts April 16th so it's coming up and
Anne's May fifteenth do you think that
generally speaking one of the biggest
problems that the blockchain this is
more general now that blockchain can
provide in areas like medicine is that
there's a lot of sort of lack of
transparency these are
opaque transactions for a lot of people
where a lot of the participants don't
have nearly as much information as
others I mean it seems to me that that's
a big opportunity here right absolutely
transparency and pricing I mean even the
example of my girlfriend that's just
crazy that in in the same city you can
basically get yeah you know it's 80%
difference in price it's just insane
so basically the same thing it's a
machine that does the MRI there's no
difference in quality there so yeah
absolutely so blockchain will do will do
all of that yeah
fascinating we've been speaking with
ildefonso Liana he's the founder and CEO
of well network you can learn more using
the link in the video description we'll
be following this closely and I really
appreciate you talking to me about it
today thank you David
great talking to you